a clear shot as it happened a missile
hits the High Altitude balloon and it
begins its descent in end to days of
long debate about what to do about this
massive air balloon suddenly we saw
something take off from the Jet and knew
it was a missile and you can see the
explosion you should have shot it down
when it first been seen instead of
letting it travel all the way across the
United States that was just stupid I
think it's
terrible that they let it get this far
and start with
and what I've heard there's more and
more of them
China claimed it was a weather balloon
that was blown off course President
Biden says he gave the order to shoot it
down last Wednesday they decided without
doing damage to anyone on on the ground
they decided that the best time to do
that was it got over water outside
within our within 12 mile limit
it successfully took it down the
Pentagon says in F-22 fighter jet
launched a single missile to bring the
balloon down into U.S territorial Waters
Pentagon officials say now they're
turning their attention to recovering
the balloon they think it's going to be
a fairly simple operation there are
already several U.S Navy and U.S Coast
Guard ships on the scene they plan to
use U.S Navy divers at unmanned
submersibles to bring it to the surface
in the next few days
and then the U.S will decide if they
want to publicly end the debate offering
proof of what this was it's still an
open debate this huge balloon was in
fact following the airstreams of the
area and that it has in fact drifted it
it's not loitering over Montana it was
shot off the Eastern Seaboard so at this
juncture this idea that this is somehow
a spy ship that was deliberately sent by
China seems a little bit far-fetched but
U.S analysts say the fact that they
believe a similar balloon is traveling
Latin America makes this Theory more
likely I do not believe that it was uh
just a weather balloon blown off course
it would be quite the coincidence if we
have this balloon going into U.S
airspace while apparently there's
another one Crossing Latin America
simultaneously infringing upon other
countries airspace another strain in an
already frayed relationship we which was
supposed to take steps toward
Improvement on Saturday instead taking a
step back Patty culhane Al Jazeera
Washington
well let's speak to Evan Resnick about
this he's an assistant professor at the
s rajaratnam school of international
studies at Nyan Technological University
is joining us from Singapore thank you
so much for being with us what do you
make of China's reaction to the shooting
down of this suspected spy balloon it
says the reaction from the U.S was
excessive and that it retains the right
to respond what might this response be
oh
uh yeah I I think this is the reaction
you would expect from both sides uh
countries spy on each other uh routinely
adversaries spy on each other uh quite
routinely the U.S uh and China spy on
each other a lot it's when one country
catches the other red-handed uh the
Temptation is is irresistible to make a
sort of propaganda Victory out of it you
can't really spy on each other uh
regularly the Chinese deny this was a
spy aircraft they say this was a
civilian weather balloon the Pentagon
saying that another Chinese balloon was
seen over South America why why would
the Chinese need a balloon over the U.S
when they have advanced satellite
systems that could do the job could
could this have been a provocation by
Beijing or more of a miscalculation
uh it would seem that in light of uh
Secretary of State Lincoln's imminent
visit to Beijing that it was unlikely to
have been a deliberate Ploy by the
Chinese uh to ramp up tensions that
would just seem unusual uh given given
the the timing it probably was a
miscalculation
so where does this leave now the
relationship between Beijing and
Washington
Secretary State blinking as you said was
due to visit a meeting that that would
it would seem the Chinese wanted will
that still go ahead and where does it
leave the relationship you think
it's unlikely to go ahead in the
imminent future uh president President
Biden's facing strong political
headwinds he doesn't want to seem like
he's uh uh appeasing the Chinese uh the
time when uh with you he's just
intercepted this uh surveillance
aircraft this uh surveillance balloon
the Republicans are all critic are are
criticizing him for not being uh
strong-willed enough in dealing with
that with that incident so it sounds
like uh any any chance of the meeting
taking place uh in the immediate future
is unlikely which is unfortunate given
as you said the relationship between the
two countries has been uh extremely
hostile over the last few years thank
you so much for speaking to us Evan
resnick's joining us there from
Singapore thank you for your time
thank you